carnet de correspondance en main les
jeunes de la verrière âgés de 11 à 15
ans venait ce mercredi en mairie pour
voter pour leurs futurs représentants au
conseil municipal des jeunes
parmi les futurs élus phare à 13 ans
déjà plein d'idées en tête faire un
skate park pour plutôt des gens qui
veulent du skate
si possible par des fêtes pour les
jeunes maîtres des dos d'âne un ou des
dés comment s'appelle des oies la
dernière dans les vides en effet à ce
que naquit roule un peu trop vite et
kenny plus jeune mais tout aussi motivés
ont couru nous avait montré des vidéos
sur le cmj et ça m'avait plu alors
jonchent inscrit c'est une
responsabilité 27 jeunes sont candidats
seuls 21 d'entre eux seront élus pour
deux ans les six autres deviendront
suppléant ce cmj est une première à la
verrière les jeunes son étal richesse
une main tel ou tel foisonnement d'idées
c'est que on peut pas passer à côté de
ça donc conçu que c'était important de
leur permet de s'exprimer
des réunions préparatoires ont permis
aux jeunes d'exposer leurs idées avant
de se présenter pour ces élections
après un premier vote aujourd'hui un
second s'effectuera jeudi jusqu'à 17
heures au collège philippe de champaigne
avant le dépouillement à 18 heures en
mairie